يا عم
[موسيقى]
مع اعداد كبيره جدا من الاصابات داخل مجمع
الشفاء الطبي بسبب ص قوات الاحتلال
لتجمعات المواطنين التي تحاول انتقاض لقمه
عيشها من على الدوار الكويتي هو المكان
الوحيد الذي تدخل اليه المساعدات من جنوب
قطاع غزه الى شمال قطاع غزه لكن قوات
الاحتلال لم تسمح لهؤلاء المواطنين التقاط
لقمه عيشهم عشرات الاصابات والممرات
امتلات بالاصابات وحتى هذه اللحظه
الاصابات تتوافد تباعا من تلك المنطقه
وصولا الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي
اعووو الكويت رموا علينا فوق العش جزائ
كله استش كله مات ايش بتعملوا على الدوار
الكويتي بجيب طحين ايش
نجيب هذا هو الحال داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
عدد كبير من الاصابات الان تصل بسبب اطلاق
قوات الاحتلال القذائف على المواطنين
الذين يحاولون انتظار المعونات واكياس
الطحين التي تدخل من جنوب قطاع غزه الى
شمال قطاع غزه حتى هذه اللحظه تتوافد
الاصابات باعداد كبيره جدا داخل
المجمع لقمه العيش اصبحت مغمسه بالدماء و
بقذائف قوات الاحتلال كل من يحاول
الاقتراب من هذه المعونات يتم اطلاق
القذائف والرصاص بشكل عنيد جدا علي معك
حاجه بنى الطحين قاعد ط علينا جزا طيب ليش
رايح تجيب طحين طعم لاولاد
ليشش
را ايش ضربوا
عليكم
بسرعه يا عم
شدك ابو
يوسف